what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar and today i have quite possibly
the most hyped topic i've ever covered
for you we are discussing nothing less
than the strongest demon slayer in
history yurichi versus demon king adult
tanjiro as they battle for the title of
the strongest in all of demon slayer if
you do enjoy these demonstrator videos
and want to keep them coming you know
what to do channel the slayer within and
smash that like button with no mercy
never forget smashing his strongest
layer of energy and passing his scared
moves on energy so choose wisely if you
haven't make this video you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications or you will miss
future demonstrator videos and updates
including exciting updates about the new
season containing best girl mitsui now i
want to thank raykhan everyday earbuds
for sponsoring this video i gotta say i
love these earbuds and not just because
red is my favorite color whether i'm
listening to music during a run
listening to an audiobook during a walk
or editing my videos in a tim hortons
raycon earbuds are perfect for their job
and raycon's everyday earbuds look feel
and sound better than ever the optimized
gel tips are very comfortable i
sometimes forget i'm wearing them and
even more importantly for me as a runner
they don't fall out i can't tell you how
many earbuds i tried and they kept
falling out during runs but that's never
happened with khan no matter how hard or
fast i run i cannot overstate how
important that is to me for my fellow
runners and anime binge watchers they
also last long offering 8 hours of play
time and a 32 hour battery life more
than enough for a marathon even so if
you're watching anime between classes or
you just don't want to bother the rest
of your family with shonen protagonist
screams raycon's got us anime lovers
covered what's even cooler is that they
cost half the price of other premium
audio brands it's really no wonder they
have over 48 thousand five star reviews
so what are you waiting for click that
link in the description box or go to buy
raycon dot com slash uproar to get 15
off your raycon purchase now without
further ado let's jump into its spoilers
and all so the setup for this video will
be similar to those old death battle
videos i watched back in the day on
youtube in the sense that we'll briefly
highlight relevant info you should know
about each character and then afterwards
we'll actually get into what will most
likely happen during the fight itself so
let's start with yorichi tsugikuni this
dude is a legend who lived nearly 500
years ago i could sing his praises for
hours the man was born with natural
talent that hasn't been seen before him
or since him for instance if you are
well acquainted with the demonstrator
story you know that every demonstrator
sort of reaches certain milestones as
they progress on their getting stronger
journey they develop a mark if they make
it far enough an even fewer amount can
turn their sword red eventually an even
fewer amount can gain access to the
transparent world eventually and an even
fewer amount can gain access to the
selfless state which tundra used to beat
upper moon 3 akaza yurichi pretty much
had access to all of these things since
birth most obviously he was born with a
demonstrator mark he wasn't actually
using a nitrogen blade back then so i
guess we can't actually say he had a red
blade as a kid but it is confirmed that
he did see the transparent world from
birth and it is heavily implied by his
behavior that he's more or less always
in the selfless state the first time he
picked up a practice sword he absolutely
destroyed a sword expert that was
training his twin brother michikatsu
michikatsu show talent in his own right
but compared to the prodigy yorichi
brother of michikatsu brother
michikatsu's pace of growth seemed as
slow as a turtle fast forward to
adulthood and after a demon took his
wife an unborn child from him he devoted
himself to becoming a demon slayer
breathing styles weren't even around
back then yurichi was the one who
created the first breath style the
breath of the sun he was the master of
this breath style his nitrogen blade was
black but would turn bright red during
battle it's made clear that no one could
match yurichi's skill and since many
people couldn't learn sun breathing he
taught them inferior variations of it
that they could learn and that's how we
got all the well-known breathing styles
like flame breathing stone breathing and
so on so that's some basic background
information but how did yurichi fare
against powerful demons well he excelled
in that too no one could touch him not
even muzon musan tried to hit yorichi
but he couldn't and before he knew it
yurichi had cut him up yurichi's bright
red blade was super effective and muzon
was confused to see that his body wasn't
regenerating properly muzon knew he
couldn't win so he did what he could he
ran he made his body burst open with
incredible force unleashing about 1 800
scattered pieces of flesh yurichi
actually cut more than 1 500 but the
remaining pieces were too small and
later went on to recombine and as a
result muzon regenerated he never risked
another confrontation with yurichi
though he avoided him until yurichi died
from old age still though muzon remained
traumatized by their encounter centuries
later when muzon is fighting against
their main characters it's revealed that
musang could never fully heal from
yorishi's attacks they remain burned
into his flesh on a cellular level
furthermore muzon refers to yorichi as
being the true monster not him so when
you have the big bad boss of the series
who's a demon king calling you the real
monster you know you're a beast even
yurichi's last moments were epic as an
over 80 year old man he confronted his
brother once more and his brother was
now the demon kokushibo against upper mu
won kokoshibo the strongest upper moon
old man yurichi did unbelievably well
for kokushibo he was nothing less than
godly yurichi didn't follow the rules of
this world and he was even the only
marked one to live on well past 25 years
old despite being old he fought like he
was still in his prime according to
kokoshibo yurichi's aura alone made
kokoshibo feel like rocks were weighing
his shoulders down like tundra against
akaza yorichi warned him that he was
coming before he actually attacked and
still kokushibo could do nothing his
neck was sliced before he could even
draw his own demon sword kukushibo said
the only reason he didn't die there was
because yorichi died of old age then
while still standing like a true boss
think whitebeard from one piece i
however am still of the opinion that
yorici hesitated to end his brother's
life because he cared about him so much
and that's why that first attack didn't
finish him off we all know yorice was
powerful enough to end it in one go as
we saw when he fought against muzon
muzon is supposed to be stronger than
kokushibo and yet yurichi had no trouble
taking his head in an instant either way
kokoshibo knew that he had been beaten
and outclassed and that he was extremely
lucky to still be alive and that's
urichi for you he beat muzon and before
he died of old age he took some time to
completely outclass the strongest upper
moon who became a demon in the hopes
that he could keep up with yorichi of
course he couldn't though no one could
except maybe contestant number two demon
king tanjiro demon king tanjiro came
about because before muzon was burned by
the sun he entrusted his feelings and
powers to tanjiru he poured into tangero
all his blood and power usually it's
said that demons with more muzan blood
tend to be stronger and it's worth
noting that this is by far the most
blood muzon ever gave to anyone he did
this because he believed that tanjiro
would conquer the sunlight muzon's
greatest weakness and go on to become
the strongest demon the king of all
demons because he shared nezuko's blood
and she conquered the sun muzon was all
but certain that tundra could do it too
so our main character and arguably the
current strongest living slayer becomes
a demon his marks spread and he gets
more marks which as i discussed in my
all tundra forms video is usually a sign
of increased power going by marks alone
we can assume that tangero has never
been stronger he sees the sun and it
burns him but as muzan predicted he
overcomes it and it eventually stops
burning him that means nitrogen blades
even bright red ones are also no longer
super effective as they were against
muzon he goes on to show his doc awk
like bony whips form and he can use
these whips to kill from a distance and
keep people from coming close at one
point giw even says sunlight and bright
red blades won't work against tunjuro
there's no way to kill him tundra also
unleashes a powerful energy orb from his
mouth that can travel and then grows on
impact and creates lightning-like
shockwaves around it it seems like he
just came from a different show since it
reminds me of bee drew bombs from naruto
or the wide variety of energy blasts
that we see in dragon ball z keep in
mind blood demon arts can grow and
evolve over time so the fact that he's
already using something so powerful
speaks volumes if you pay close
attention this attack creates wind and
lightning around it so and this is just
a theory i just thought of but it kind
of makes sense to me it's possible that
tangier as the chosen sun breather demon
can incorporate all elements into his
attacks since they all come from sun
breathing think about how upper moon 4's
hatred clone could use so many different
abilities i think demon king tangero
would definitely fit into that basket
some might argue that he hasn't proven
that he can survive beheading and thus
he might actually be killable but that
wouldn't really make sense muzon
survived decapitation and akuza and
kokoshibo were capable of doing so so it
would just make no sense for the
strongest demon who got all of muzon's
blood and is immune to the sun to be
killable through decapitation they never
actually took his head but i think it's
a very safe assumption to think that
nichiren blades wouldn't be capable of
finishing off this sun immune demon
since tundra is immune to the sun
properties in nichiren blades it would
just be like some other demon taking off
their own head like rui did and even if
tundra wasn't immune to the sun you can
argue with all of muzon's blood it's
more likely than not that he could grow
the head back but since he is immune
it's just unimaginable that the sun
properties in nutrient blades would do
anything eventually kano comes injects
him with become a human again medicine
and with the help of tundra's friends
and his own principles he reverts back
to normal we only got a glimpse of what
tundra was capable of as a demon king
before he turned back so we can't be
sure how he would have hypothetically
turned out if he kept walking down that
path but we can imagine chances are he
would eventually move beyond his berserk
and wild phase and become like kokoshibo
and kaigaku meaning a demon that can use
their breathing style except it's
improved because it is enhanced through
their increased demon speed power and
blood demon art over time tangero could
become a demon adult like nezuko morphs
into a much more mature looking mode to
mark her increased power and this demon
king adult tanjiro would have access to
all the sun breathing forms but
potentially he could shoot off elemental
orbs from his flashes or just generate
elements in creative ways think about
lightning emitting from his sword so
people can't approach or launching gusts
of actual physical wind at opponents or
perhaps even launching mini suns at his
opponents he could set the battlefield
on fire to burn his opponent and if he
is affected by his own fire which
wouldn't be the case if it works like
nezu's fire then at least he can
regenerate later while his human
opponent wouldn't be able to and if he
faced another demon he could just
overpower them and absorb them into
himself as i mentioned in my all tendril
forms video it's possible he could even
create many exploding sun that engulfed
a large area but whereas his human
opponents couldn't survive tundra could
potentially regenerate if he is in fact
affected by them so now let's get to the
fight what would happen if the strongest
slayer ever battled the strongest demon
ever as mentioned we are looking at if
tundra walked down the path of a demon
and actually became capable of using his
breathing style with demon enhancements
chances are yurichi would still be
quicker since he performed so well
against muzon and no one was ever able
to lay a hand on him before so yorichi
would go in slashing tundra multiple
times before tunjuro could ever hope to
hit him yorichi might even use his
completed 13 forms and keep the combo
going so that tundra would get cut
repeatedly the hope would be that tundra
wouldn't be able to counter attack
between attacks the issue is though that
yurichi's bright red blade made it
difficult for muzon to regenerate but
for tanjiro it wouldn't have the same
effect in fact we could imagine tundra's
body reacting like muzons when iguro cut
through him meaning the first cut would
already be healed by the time yurichi's
blade exits on the other end of the body
yurichi could buy some time perhaps by
kicking off sliced parts of tundra's
body before they can reattach but since
tunjuro would be the strongest demon
ever it's safe to say that even from
scratch he could regrow limbs quickly
also since there isn't that burning
paralyzing effect happening within demon
king tangero since the red blades don't
affect him in the same way he could
potentially choose to emit elements from
his body as yurichi is slicing him
imagine lightning being emitted and
paralyzing yarichi or flames that start
a spreading fire in such a case yorichi
may be paralyzed for even a second but
that would be enough for demon king
tundra to turn the tides keep in mind
although not as proficient in it even
tundra could gain access to transparent
world and selfless state as a human so
with his demon enhancements and the time
he had to master it all he'd be
considerably faster than muzon was and
even if you argue the selfless state is
something that can't be used as a demon
we all know that kokoshibo could see the
transparent world so tundra would
definitely have that still my point is
it will only take a hiccup on yorichi's
part for demon king tundra to take
advantage even a scratch from tanjiro
and this may even apply to damage caused
by his elemental attacks would start
spreading poison in yurichi's body and
slowing him down meaning he would be
fighting a losing battle think about how
kaigaku's black lightning tore apart
zaintsu's flesh and was going to kill
him if yushiro didn't stop it from
spreading so yurichi best case scenario
could attack tundra fast enough and
effectively enough for tundra to be
incapable of launching a counter attack
but even with this best case scenario
tundra would always be able to recover
yurichi could run at full speed for a
day and a night as a kid without getting
tired no problem so in his prime you can
bet he'd be able to go for a long time
days even but eventually he would give
out if only from lack of water and food
if nothing else so in this best case
scenario where yurichi's attacks would
be effective enough to keep tundra from
releasing even elemental counter-attacks
yurichi would still eventually lose thus
there are too many ways tundra could
beat yurichi in no way that demon king
tundra could be killed by urichi so the
winner despite how awesome yurichi is
would have to be demon king tanjiro
that's not to take anything away from
yorichi who's my favorite character and
as far as humans go he is by far the
strongest human ever and even stronger
than all other demons except for demon
king tangier and that is it for this
video i hope you enjoyed it let me know
your thoughts on it and if you'd like to
see any other similar matchups if you
did like it you know what to do channel
the slayer within and smash that like
button with no mercy never forget
smashing is strongest layer energy and
passing is scared moose on energy so
choose wisely if you haven't make this
the video subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future demonstrator videos and updates
including exciting updates about the new
season containing best girl mitsuri you
know you don't want to miss that so hit
that notification bell and while you
wait for the next video to drop feel
free to check out my huge and growing
demonstrator playlist that includes
videos in all hashira demon moons and
much more link to that is in the
description and until next time see ya
space cowboys